so for all the talk about Donald Trump's
weirdness in this particular election
cycle it turns out that Hillary Clinton
and her team are way way weirder the
media have simply chosen not to reported
on Friday
WikiLeaks filled an email showing the
Clinton campaign chair John Podesta was
invited to a spirit cooking AB spirit by
Marina Abramovic along with John's
brother Tony as power to sell a report
spirit cooking often incorporates human
elements particularly blood breastmilk
urine and sperm in ritualistic cooking
its origins are found in cake of light a
supposedly spiritual foods ingredients
include plenty oil menstrual blood and
sperm like this is really a real thing
in a reddit forum Abramovich told users
the context of the ritual depends
heavily on intention performing it in a
gallery or a studio makes it art
performing it in the confines of one's
home makes it more intimate and
spiritual Abramovich also recommends
eating the pain after cutting your
middle finger using fresh urine to wash
away nightmare dreams and mixing fresh
breast milk with fresh sperm milk for
earthquake nights this is real but Trump
is the weirdo Hillary's oddities gone
unreported by the media for literally
decades according to Bob Woodward
hillary bought sheet in houston clos
director of the foundation for mind
research for the White House when
Hillary was first lady there Hillary
held seances with Eleanor Roosevelt and
Mahatma Gandhi she said she thought it
would be a step too far talks of Jesus
though Hillary wrote that Eleanor quote
usually responds by telling me to buck
up or at least to glow skin as thick as
a rhinoceros Hillary by the way also
likes to throw back the alcohol her
former campaign manager current corrupt
Virginia Governor Terry McAuliffe she
said quote she loves to sit throw them
back we all hear about the story she and
John McCain actually had a shot contest
I think in the Ukraine or somewhere
around the world and she actually beat
John McCain in the shot contest at a
quote so Hillary isn't exactly the
paragon of stoic sobriety she's an odd
lady surrounded by odd people will do
odd and terrible things as president
just don't expect the media to report it
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
okay lots to talk about today and and I
want to start by apologizing for some of
the technical oddities on the show
obviously for watching this on Facebook
live for watching it on daily wire
that's just because I'm broad I'm over
in Austin and Austin as a blue area has
decided that censorship is obviously the
best possibility in any case lots going
on let's start with this Podesta story
because everybody's covering this a
little bit wrong I mean there's no
evidence that John Podesta is a Satanist
yeah there's not there's evidence the
Marina Abramovic is a weirdo and the
John Podesta is a weirdo and a Tony put
us two they're all weirdos there's no
evidence that they go around worshiping
vehicles worshipping Satan and honestly
having Alex Jones and company pushing
theories about the occult and those
being taken seriously let's not go over
the top they're weird that should freak
you out but it's more about them being
environmentalists wildlife weirdos then
it has to do with them worshipping Satan
I don't I don't know any evidence today
worship Satan per se it seems bad enough
to me that they're ingesting food made
from other people's sperm by the way is
there has there ever been a plenty
scandal doesn't involve sperm yeah I
think we're still searching for a
Clinton scandal that doesn't involve
sperm I think but meanwhile it's pretty
clear that the the left is freaking out
right now here's where the polls are so
according to the Real Clear Politics
poll average Hillary has moved to a
little bit more of a lead than she had
yesterday but in the State polling
here's where we are in the state bowling
Hillary with one point two percentage
point lead in Florida
if she wins Florida the elections over
Trump with a three point three
percentage lead in Iowa Ohio Clinton up
three in Pennsylvania that's very narrow
New Hampshire with tongue up 1.5 trump
up 0.8 in North Carolina Clinton up 2.6
in Colorado Trump up two in Nevada and
in Wisconsin to Hillary's up big
Michigan she's a big Maine she's up in
Virginia she's a big Georgia Trump is up
i aux represent so what does that mean
what that means that this entire
election as always seems like it's gonna
come down to Florida if these polls are
right now my own suspicion is that
Trump's lack of a ground game means that
he's going to underperform a lot of
these polls but I will say that it's so
volatile there's really no way to tell
at this point in the 538 broadcast in
the 538 calculation
they say that there's about a three
point lead for Hillary Clinton their
averages now making about a three point
lead for Hillary Clinton and so the
Democrats are panicking and they're
making asses in themselves as usual
except more than usual so here is Barack
Obama yesterday very very upset Donald
Trump who says the Donald Trump is bad
because he only hangs out with
celebrities you spent a lot of time with
celebrities spends a lot of time hanging
out with the really wealthy folk but you
don't see him hanging out with working
people unless they're cleaning his room
or mowing the fairways on his Golf Club
you're gonna make this guy your champion
if you're a working person somebody who
spent his life without ever showing any
regard for working folks but he has
insulted minorities and immigrants and
Muslims and Americans with disabilities
that's the voice you want you want a
voice who's bragging about how being
famous lets you get away with what would
qualify sexual assault and cause women
pigs and dogs and slobs okay we can stop
it there so Barack Obama goes down he
says he only hangs out with celebrities
he doesn't care about working people in
any real way okay really really okay so
it but from but but presumably Obama
does Obama spends all his time pretty
much every single day meeting with
celebrities in fact there's somebody
online who's saying that President
Carter the defense secretary is actually
the President of the United States Obama
is just the celebrity in chief and it's
pretty clear that that's how Obama sees
the presidency one of the great ironies
of this particular election cycle is
that President Obama can't believe that
a reality TV star like Donald Trump
might take his place the great good God
came Barack Obama might be replaced by
this dumb by this dumb ass Donald Trump
but here's the here's the real out of
the reality of how people see Barack
Obama they don't see Barack Obama as
some great statesman they don't see
Obama the same way Obama sees Obama
Obama sees himself is a great world
leader Obama sees himself as a great god
genius Obama sees himself as this
wonderful fellow who's gonna lead us
from the darkness to the light most
Americans see Barack Obama the same way
they see Lady Gaga except he has more
power and he doesn't do this many weird
sexual things on tape that Barack Obama
is just a celebrity to them this is why
celebrities worship Obama so Obama
ripping on Trump from meeting with
celebrities I mean the fact is that
Trump celebrity connections are so much
less than Obama's celebrity connections
to make your head swim I mean Obama is
constantly meeting at the White House
with everybody from 9/11 truther math or
more to Beyonce who talks from teamily
about what she wants to do with her P
word in her songs and that's no problem
for Obama so one of the big problems
with American elections now is that it's
impossible to make a credible charge
against your opponent because
everybody's in the gutter so Obama says
that Trump is a celebrity that's true
but Obama's a celebrity and he's the one
who made it that way he's the one who
solicited that he's the one who has
sought celebrity status by going on
Samantha be like three days ago
so again none of this washes Obama by
the way acknowledges that Hillary
Clinton is really a bad candidate it
should have invested in the clothing
industry before this election because
there are so many people who are holding
their noses and voting it's just
absolutely insane here is President
Obama holding his nose about Hillary
Clinton when I hear young people who
tell me well you know I'm not that
interested or I don't think my vote
makes a difference or even though Trump
is terrible but you know Hillary is not
exciting me that's when I hear that
stuff I I just have to have to say the
world is imperfect politics is imperfect
candidates are imperfect I'm imperfect
you make choices you decide on what is
best in this particular situation and in
this particular situation it's not even
close Hillary Clinton is somebody who's
qualified to be president and cares
about the issues that Millennials care
about and will maintain the progress
that we've made over these last eight
years I love it I mean President Obama
they're basically praising himself to
the sky like well I like the point where
he says I'm imperfect and you can see
that he thinks he's lying down President
Obama's saying yourself remember I'll
have nobody nobody's perfect except for
except for me but he's basically
admitting there Hillary's awful you just
have to vote for Hillary to stop Trump
on the other side you have everybody
saying the opposite you have everybody
saying they have to vote for Trump to
stop Hillary nobody likes to Lori nobody
likes from it's awful and you can see
that the Democrats are freaking out
about this because if this election is a
referendum on Hillary Clinton instead of
Donald Trump Hillary loses that's the
way this works when it was in referendum
on Donald Trump Hillary was winning
because nobody wants to see Trump be
president if in the American mind this
referendum this elections now referendum
on Hillary Clinton Hillary's in serious
trouble because nobody likes her so it
really is a mindset if the media covers
Hillary more in the last week and a half
leading up to the election major
advantage from if they covered some
moreover the weekend major advantage to
Hillary Clinton and that's why I see two
Democrats in panic mode two Tim Kaine
the presidential candidate he's whining
now the Congress is saying they're going
to investigate Hillary Clinton he's
desperately trying to get the attention
off of Hillary Clinton in the last days
of this election cycle people are on the
impeachment word around before the
election has even taken place I mean
first it kind of suggests a little bit
of defeat isn't like well we think we're
probably going to lose second it also
suggests a really bad view of what the
role of a legislator is shame about this
investigation stuff oh you know I
thought legislators were supposed to
legislate
I mean investigations are part of it but
the real issue is legislation so I hope
folks voters will hold them accountable
don't tell us just what you're gonna
block tell us what it is that you want
to do yeah it's supposedly about about
legislation that's the real problem here
is that the legislation as all has all
broken down it's a minute isn't how
they're trying to shift blame we need a
lot of the Democrats are complete
disarray Bernie Sanders he's out there
campaigning for Hillary and he's at the
same time Barack Obama's friends get off
the boat on the basis that Barack Obama
is the greatest president ever and we
have to continue this winning streak
Bernie Sanders is out there saying oh by
the way Brock Obama's not a very good
president and things up for grabs Bernie
Sanders final note from from socialist
septuagenarian Bernie Sanders
okay so Bernie Sanders is very upset
about the state of the economy real
unemployment is too high we need more
socialism except for the fact that you
need more black voters to show up in
vote and you got a problem there because
black voters aren't interested in voting
for Hillary Clinton Robby Mook who is
Hillary's communications director he's
out there trying to get the focus off
Hillary Clinton saying Hillary's been
cleared and she'll be cleared again none
of this is a big deal I am totally
confident when the FBI says what they
have they get the information out there
there's gonna be nothing new he said he
didn't even know what the emails were we
found out he didn't even have a warrant
to look at them at the time he sent out
the letter we're just saying get the
information out there on the table the
voters are smart Hillary has been
cleared on this she'll be cleared again
and we'll move forward and focus on what
we care about in this election which is
kids and families and how we're helping
people afford education and health care
you know I needs a big round of applause
of course from the audience of the view
for that but the fact is that most
people don't think that Hillary is
necessarily going to be cleared unless
something really really corrupt happens
now
all of this would be good news for
Donald Trump going into the final
weekend except for Christopher
McChrystal so you remember Chris
Christie he's the fellow who's been
destroying the Republican Party for the
last eight years so chris Christie I
have never seen any one person had this
sort of impact on a presidential on
presidential races two times in a row if
you remember back to 2012 Chris Christie
spoke at the Republican National
Convention he'd been vetted for
vice-president and rejected because Mitt
Romney thought that he was kind of
corrupt and Chris Christie still got the
keynote at the RNC where he proceeded to
spend the entire keynote talking about
how wonderful he was instead of talking
about Mitt Romney his speech bomb then
you remember the week before the
election he hugged President Obama
talked in glowing terms about what a
great guy President Obama was how
President Obama was was this great
fellow for coming down to New Jersey
right after Hurricane sandy and they
walked arm-in-arm down the Atlantic City
Boardwalk and they they made sweet love
under the trees at midnight and
barack obama ends up winning the
election narrowly in large part because
of the the backlash to to hurricane
sandy and the feeling that did he do
good a job during hurricane sandy and
and chris christie helped push that
perception this year chris christie was
responsible for the murder suicide to
took out marco rubio the guy who's most
likely gonna be the nominee if chris
christie hadn't excoriated him in that
new hampshire debate leading donald
trump to quash Rubio's momentum in new
hampshire
let me get Trump is the nominee that's
bad enough now to of Chris Christie's
top aides have been convicted on all
charges in Bridgegate that's going to be
the news the media run with this weekend
Chris Christie's the head of Donald
Trump's transition team into the White
House obviously the media are going to
now attempt to ship their coverage away
from Hillary's corruption to Chris
Christie's corruption and therefore
Trump corruption that's gonna be the
message so well done chris Christie you
are absolutely indisputably be
absolutely worse and meanwhile that the
fact is that you know the Christie
surrogates are doing the film surrogates
are doing him no great favors obviously
and I'm sorry we have to sign off now
with the folks on Facebook live but to
go over to Daily wire calm and you can
watch the rest of this live our quality
of broadcast will be better next week
I'll be back in the studio next week not
on the road so much but by an obviously
lonely part of a mail bag if you want to
get all these special goodies we're
about to roll on some brand new special
goodies if you're an annual subscriber
get a free copy of my book to legions
which is doing really well in the in the
charts and you get a free signed copy if
you're an annual subscriber plus you get
clave ins Show Live and his mailbag and
lots of other big babies I'm gonna daily
wire doctor and become a subscriber we
are the largest conservative podcast in
the United States
you